noch vor weihnachten gegensteuern weil
immer mehr menschen an corona sterben
fordert die kanzlerin härtere alltags
beschränkungen so schnell wie möglich
viel versprochen wenig getan die welt
hängt ihren klimazielen hinterher und
die uno mahnt zur eile
alles gegeben verdient weiter rb leipzig
schießt sich gegen manchester united in
die ko-runde der champions league auch
dortmund gewinnt
[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nimmt in allen an
diesem mittwoch um 7
schön dass sie dabei sind katja ist auch
dabei für den sport nachher in der
sendung und hat auch noch ein gesamtes
thema aus der champions league sehr
guten abend es ist der tag an dem dieses
land so viele tote zu betrauern hat die
an oder mit corona gestorben sind wie
noch nie 590 neue todesfälle innerhalb
eines tages meldet das
robert-koch-institut diese entwicklung
prägt heute die sogenannte
generaldebatte im deutschen bundestag
eigentlich geht es darum den haushalt
die bundeskanzlerin räumte ein die
vielen neuen schulden bedeuteten
einschränkungen für kommende
generationen
aber im mittelpunkt der debatte steht
dann die frage wie die pandemie in
deutschland in den griff zu bekommen ist
andreas ruppert keine generaldebatte der
üblichen art der haushalt und die
schulden spielen eine untergeordnete
rolle in angela merkels rede vielmehr
geht zum infektionszahlen um die vielen
toten
die kanzlerin macht klar sie will
strengere kontakt beschränkungen das tut
mir wirklich am herzen
aber wenn wir dafür den preis zahlen
dass wir todeszahl von tag am tag 590
menschen haben dann ist das nicht
akzeptabel
noch vor weihnachten brauche es
zusätzliche maßnahmen nur so könne man
der lage herr werden wir jetzt vor
weihnachten zu viele kontakte haben und
anschließend es das letzte weihnachten
mit den großeltern war dann werden wir
etwas versäumt haben das sollten wir die
spuren die afg stellt die wirkungen der
anti corona maßnahmen insgesamt in frage
allen voran die kontakt beschränken auch
nach einem dreivierteljahr stochern sie
immer noch im nebel und klammern sich an
die untaugliche holzhammermethode lockte
die mehr kollateralschäden anrichtet als
nutzen statt der harten maßnahmen jetzt
hätte die bundesregierung viel früher
reagieren müssen so die fdp viele
unternehmen fürchteten nun wieder um die
existenz amos kritisieren dass der
sommer und viele monate und die
möglichkeiten des gesamtstaats nicht
genutzt wurden und genau diese situation
vor der wir jetzt stehen ab
wenden linke und grüne vermissen im
regierungskonzept versprochene
verbesserungen für die die in der krise
besonders hart arbeiten müssen
pflegekräfte in den mittelpunkt stellen
das heißt ganz konkret auch nach dieser
pandemie ersparen nicht nur auf die
krankenhäuser jetzt zuschauen sondern
ein vorsorge element in krankenhäusern
zu schaffen alle die sie selber her
sagen den laden am laufen halten dass
die endlich das bekommen was ihnen
wirklich zusteht nämlich anständige
löhne anständige arbeitsbedingungen eine
generaldebatte im zeichen der pandemie
und im zeichen bevorstehender strengerer
bundesweiter kontakt beschränkungen
bringen wir auch heute abend wieder theo
koll mit dazu in die sendung guten abend
auf der einen seite appelle der
kanzlerin schnell zu handeln
auf der anderen seite warten wir auch
heute abend auf einen termin für die
nächste dieser ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen auf denen das dann
entschieden werden müsste wie passt das
zusammen
nun es wird möglicherweise gerade
passend gemacht seit einer stunde so
hören wir besprechen sich die
sogenannten aaa länder also die spd
geführten bundesländer wie sie mit den
forderungen nach verschärfung und einem
neuerlichen treffen umgehen und vieles
deutet jetzt auf den kommenden sonntag
also den dritten advent als termin für
die nächste corona konferenz aber sicher
ist es natürlich erst wenn es
beschlossen und verkündet wurde die
argumentation derjenigen
ministerpräsidenten die bisher
zurückhaltend sind lautet wir haben doch
schon beim letzten mal all die
möglichkeiten zu schärferen maßnahmen
beschlossen also wäre es für nötig hält
kann ja in seinem bundesland verschärfen
die bedingungen des kanzleramts dagegen
ist wir treffen uns nur wieder wenn es
darüber hinaus noch zu weiteren
verschärfungen kommt die vorbereitung
diese hürde zu nehmen die laufen
jedenfalls im moment sagt theo koll in
berlin vielen dank und das sind die
zahlen die aufgrund der gemeldeten
positiven tests die situation in
deutschland beschreiben
das robert koch institut meldet 20 1815
neuinfektionen das sind 3545 mehr als
vor einer woche
die zahl der an oder in verbindung mit
dem virus gestorbenen ist wie am anfang
der sendung bereits gesagt
so hoch wie noch nie welche schicksale
hinter diesen zahlen stehen das zeigt
jetzt thomas garcia ein video für
georgius weil jedes einblick in eine
zeit vor corona bevor enge zusammensein
verboten war und bevor er sein 90
jähriger vater starb alleine im
krankenhaus kontakt dahin gab es nur per
telefon
ich habe jedes mal schweren herzanfall
bekommen willst festnetz oder
mobiltelefon gelingen kann ich habe
immer gehofft und dann ist dieser
einrichtung wochenende rabattcodes nicht
mehr weit lange es geht
es geht vorbei ein besuch beim vater
nicht möglich infektionsgefahr wurde ihm
gesagt dass sterben man cupid 19 es ist
oft einsam wie die infektionen die
sterbefälle verhindern und zugleich wie
ein einsames weihnachten vermeiden
die bundesregierung setzt auch auf ffp
zwei masken 3 gibt's kostenlos für
ältere und vor erkrankte in apotheken
vor heiligabend schon an weihnachten
wohl hatte beschränkungen und ich finde
es in einer pandemie wofür über 500
menschen allein in den letzten 24
stunden klar ist hart und betrüblich
dass sie weihnachten gar nicht mehr
erleben werden und ihre angehörigen
trauern werden ist das für uns doch
zumutbar weihnachten mal einmal etwas
anders zu machen
und kommendes jahr intensivmediziner
fordern einen plan und dieses konzept
danach darf nicht sein
die türen gehen wieder weit auch nein
wir werden mit einschränkungen weit im
januar februar märz einfach leben müssen
härtere maßnahmen bayern hat sieht
nachts teils ausgangssperre tags
ausgangs beschränkung frust und
verständnis wir sind alle regeln recht
hauptsache dieser corona virus oder
ganze zusagen quarantäne nimmt einfach
immer man ende
das alles wird wie früher wohl der
wunsch nummer eins dieses weihnachten
und in dieser situation fordern
intensivmediziner ab sofort deutlich
mehr beschränkungen lockerungen an
weihnachten würden im januar die
krankenhäuser an den rand des machbaren
bringen sagen sie zur verdeutlichung
dieser vergleich das hier ist die
entwicklung der gemeldeten
neuinfektionen seit mitte märz
und dazu dass hier die zahl der
gemeldeten corona toten sie entwickelt
sich immer mit mehreren wochen versatz
und steigt immer noch deutlich wie die
lage auf einer intensivstation aktuell
ist zeigt seine freitag am beispiel
homburg an der saar
immer wenn er in den sensiblen cupid
bereich seiner intensivstation geht muss
professor philip lepper mehrere
schichten sicherheitskleidung tragen das
gleiche gilt für unser team
leben retten ist hier die aufgabe jeden
tag nicht immer schaffen sie das vor
einer halben stunde ist wieder ein
patient gestorben er war 42 jahre alt
einer von vielen in den letzten wochen
leider gott ist so viele dass ich selber
nicht mehr nicht mehr gezählt habe wir
sind der intensivstationen die einiges
gewohnt ist wir hatten gleichwohl so
eine hohe belastung eigentlich noch
im moment sind 14 seiner kollegen krank
gemeldet vier davon selbst infiziert die
belastung enorm
mit sorge blickt man an der uni klinik
auf weihnachten und die geplanten
lockerungen dann ist es natürlich schon
so dass leute die sich um die
weihnachtstage um infizieren
dass die dann mitte januar auf
intensivstationen sind und mitte februar
sind dann unter diesen menschen auch die
ersten toten wirtschaftliche und soziale
faktoren auf der einen seite
infektionszahlen auf der anderen
gratwanderung wenn man allerdings eben
jetzt wirklich mit blick auf die
todeszahlen eben eine deutliche
verringerung erreichen wollen dann wird
man eben wahrscheinlich nicht um diese
verschärfung der maßnahmen drum herum
kommen viele blätter und seine kollegen
wünschen sich weniger cupid kranke einen
harten lockdown auch wenn es schwer
fällt bei zdf heute live berichtet ein
chefarzt von intensivstationen am limit
sie können ihm ihre fragen stellen auf
zdf heute.de und in unserer app ab 19
uhr 30
von einer toxischen mischung spricht der
innenminister in baden württemberg es
geht um die sogenannten selbsternannten
querdenker in dem bundesland die werden
jetzt vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
seit monaten gibt es in ganz deutschland
proteste gegen die korona maßnahmen mit
dabei impfgegner und esoteriker aber
auch sogenannte reichs bürger und
rechtsextremisten
alles begann in stuttgart mit kleinen
demos jetzt prüft der verfassungsschutz
die nähe zu extremisten simon pfanzelt
baden württemberg das ist die keimzelle
der selbsternannten querdenker und baden
württemberg ist nun das erste bundesland
in dem der verfassungsschutz die
bewegung beobachtet
dabei geht es nicht um die demonstranten
im fokus der behörden stehen die
querdenken organisatoren
die querdenken organisation kooperiert
mit einschlägig bekannten akteuren und
gruppierungen aus dem milieu der reichs
bürger uns selbstverwaltung sowie dem
rechtsextremismus michael ball weg ist
der umstrittene gründer von querdenken
er scheut sich nicht vor kontakten zu
rechtsextremen wie etwa dem wegen
volksverhetzung verurteilten
videoblogger nicolai nerling in einer
pressemitteilung bezeichnet ball weg
quer denken heute als demokratiebewegung
die beobachtung sehen wir als einen
weiteren versuch der regierung an
friedliche demonstranten einzuschüchtern
und über diese nachricht zu spalten
immer wieder sind reichs flaggen zu
sehen auf querdenken demos rechtsextreme
und reichs bürger marschieren und
bundesweit mit die behörden sie in
anhaltspunkte für extremistische
bestrebungen man stellt das grundgesetz
als besatzungs recht da es wird auf
demonstrationen von rethmann aufgerufen
zum explizit aufgerufen zum widerstand
die sogenannten querdenker ein phänomen
deshalb morgen auch die
innenministerkonferenz beschäftigen wird
unser nächstes thema heute abend jetzt
geht es um 1,8 billionen euro den
haushalt der eu nämlich im streit darum
zeichnet sich jetzt kurz vor dem gipfel
in brüssel morgen eine lösung ab es gebe
eine einigung von ungarn und polen mit
der deutschen ratspräsidentschaft sagt
die polnische regierung ungarn und polen
hatten ihre zustimmung zu dem haushalt
verweigert und da ist auch ein großer
corona hilfsfonds mit dabei der grund
die eu plant künftig den ländern die
gelder zu kürzen
die rechtsstaatliche grundsätze
verletzen
stefan leifert ist unser mann in brüssel
stefan wer hat denn da am ende den
kürzeren gezogen ungarn und polen oder
die rechtsstaatlichkeit in der eu also
sicher haben beide seiten bei diesem
kompromiss federn gelassen
die größeren aber sicher ungarn und
polen wenn dieser kompromiss jetzt
morgen den eu-gipfel passieren würde
dann würde es dabei bleiben dass die eu
künftig die möglichkeit hätte
länder die gegen die rechtsstaatlichkeit
verstoßen
künftig gelder zu entziehen zwei
zugeständnisse in richtung ungarn und
polen hat die eu-seite gemacht das erste
zugeständnis ist eine erklärung die noch
mal ganz klar stellt dass es nur um
rechtsstaatlichkeit verstöße geht die
unmittelbar eu-gelder betreffen also
korruption könnte man dann
beispielsweise ahnten verletzungen von
minderheitenrechten aber nicht das
zweite zugeständnis ist dass das das
ganze erst in kraft treten soll wenn der
europäische gerichtshof in luxemburg ein
urteil gefällt hat und das wird
frühestens für 2022 erwartet also da
würden ungarn und polen noch mal ein
bisschen zeit gewinnen und victor aber
könnte in den nächsten wahlkampf zu
hause gehen ohne dass der sanktionen aus
brüssel fürchten muss unter dem strich
wenn das ganze so käme wäre ist aber ein
erfolg für aldi in der eu die seit
jahren da war darauf hinarbeiten dass es
einen solchen mechanismus endlich gibt
dargestellt wird diese wichtigen
erläuterungen heute abend aus brüssel
die mannschaft des designierten us
präsidenten joe biden nimmt konkretere
formen an
auch das pentagon soll ein weggefährte
aus der obama ära leiten der
pensionierte general lloyd austin
ein anerkannter experte aber keine
unumstrittene wahl unter anderem weil er
im ruhestand bei der rüstungsindustrie
angehört hatte während beiden am
kabinett arbeitet schmettern gerichte
immer mehr vorwürfe aus dem trump lager
ab es habe wahlfälschung gegeben britta
jäger für donald trump besteht weiter
kein zweifel er habe die wahl gewonnen
auch bei seinem corona impfgipfel nutzt
der präsident die bühne um seine
betrugsvorwürfe loszuwerden und ist
optimistisch dass das oberste us-gericht
ihm beispringt wir werden sehen wer die
nächste regierung stellt wir haben
gewonnen
mal gucken ob irgendjemand mutig genug
ist ob ein oder mehrere richter am
supreme court
lasst uns sehen ob sie den mut haben das
zutun von dem jeder in diesem land weiß
dass es richtig ist
doch jetzt beschert ihm das oberste
gericht eine schwere niederlage
mit einem antrag auf einstweilige
verfügung wollten die republikaner hier
joe biden 2-sieg in pennsylvania kippen
doch selbst die von trump kürzlich
ernannte richterin amy kunibert lehnte
den antrag ab
die entscheidung des gerichts ein
ständig kein guter tag für trump auch im
repräsentantenhaus die überwältigende
mehrheit stimmte für den neuen
verteidigungshaushalt obwohl trump wegen
einiger streitpunkte mit veto droht die
meisten republikaner ignorierten ihn
männer und frauen in uniform riskieren
ihr leben wir schulden ihnen die mittel
damit sie ihren job machen können
auch der republikanisch geführte senat
wird wohl ähnlich abstimmen wendet sich
dieses mal gegen st dennoch scheint der
präsident seine partei weiter im griff
zu haben
nach wie vor traut sich fast niemand
trumps gegner beiden als wahlsieger
anzuerkennen
fünf jahre ist es her dass sich die welt
auf das pariser klima-abkommen geeinigt
hat das ziel die erderwärmung stoppen
vor allem dadurch dass weniger
treibhausgase ausgestoßen werden
gegenüber dem vorindustriellen zeitalter
soll die erwärmung auf maximal zwei grad
begrenzt werden
besser noch auf 1,5 grad erreicht hat
man noch nicht viel die erde ist bereits
jetzt rund 1,2 grad wärmer geworden
waren die uno marco go berichtet
weihnachtswünsche an die kanzlerin von
klimaaktivisten sie aber auch die
experten des uno-umweltprogramms fordern
mehr engagement im kampf gegen die
klimakrise in einer neuen studie mahnen
sie wird nur so viel getan wie bisher
steigt der ausstoß von treibhausgasen
weiter an die erderwärmung würde auf
katastrophale 3,2 grad zu laufen für die
im klima vertrag festgelegte zwei grad
obergrenze müsste die kurve scharf
abknicken und noch mehr um das
wunschziel von möglichst 1,5 grad zu
erreichen wir gehen davon aus dass die
globalen emissionen ungefähr stagnieren
in den nächsten zehn jahren um das klima
sinnvoll zu schützen müssten sie aber
halbiert werden in den nächsten zehn
jahren also wir sind weit weg von dem
was eigentlich passieren müsste aber es
kommt bewegung in die klimapolitik der
künftige us-präsident will zurück in den
klimavertrag von paris und auch andere
länder haben dieses jahr ihre
langfristigen ziele verschärft es
scheint sich in der tat
ein wendepunkt abzuzeichnen das liegt
daran dass immer mehr länder sich
vornehmen komplett aus kohle öl und gas
auszusteigen
also klimaneutralität anzustreben
das hat angefangen mit großbritannien
dann ist die eu mit eingestiegen jetzt
als größter emittent auch china bis 2060
will das reich der mitte klimaneutral
sein
deutschland hat ähnlich ambitionierte
ziele es hakt aber hier noch beim wind
ausbau im verkehrssektor und auch der
kohle ausstieg kommt spät erst 2038 ob
die weihnachtswünsche der aktivisten
wirklich in erfüllung gehen ist da noch
völlig offen
so und jetzt in der sendung fußball
katja genau so sieht's aus borussia
dortmund steht durch ein 2 1 bei zenith
st petersburg im achtelfinale der
champions league und das sogar als
gruppen-erster rb leipzig hat es
ebenfalls in die ko runde geschafft mit
einem verdienten 3 2 sieg gegen den
englischen rekordmeister manchester
united
jubel und erleichterung bei julia
nagelsmann gulasch erhielt in der
nachspielzeit die führung fest sind sehr
glücklich die jungs haben in der kabine
sehr gelöst gewirkt an allen drei
leipziger toren war der spanier antonio
maßgeblich beteiligt hatte schon nach
zwei minuten zum 1 0 getroffen
ein zweifelhafter elfmeter und ein
glücklicher treffer zum 2 3 brachte
manchester united in der schlussphase
noch heran aber mehr gelang den
engländern nicht leipzigs torhüter
gulasch hat den großen anteil am sieg
bleibt sich also weiter nur ist noch
nicht klar ob als gruppen erster oder
zweiter denn das parallelspiel in der
gruppe h gestern abend zwischen paris
und dem türkischen klub istanbul baksi
hier wurde nach 14 minuten abgebrochen
der grund der vierte offizielle soll den
istanbuler assistenztrainer rassistisch
beleidigt haben
sie wollten ein signal setzen beide
teams verliessen das spielfeld nachdem
der vierte offizielle sebastian kohl
tesco den co-trainer von rasak schien
ihr pia weber als [ __ ] bezeichnet hatte
was schwarz auf rumänisch bedeutet und
von spielern beider mannschaften als
rassistisch empfunden wurde
entsetzen weltweit aber auch anerkennung
für das deutliche zeichen dass beide
mannschaften gesetzt haben
die höhe weiß ich gesehen habe wie die
spieler protestiert haben wie sie nein
gesagt haben zudem war so passiert ist
dabei stolz stolz darauf zu sehen dass
das im fußball passiert so wie viele
andere twitterte psg star kilian im
papier sein nein zu rassismus und wbo
wir stehen zu dir
teamkollege neymar twitterte black ops
meter die uefa kündigte unterdessen eine
gründliche untersuchung des vorfalls an
und das spiel wird heute an fortgesetzt
ab der 15 minute hat ja danke schön
jetzt können wir uns alle gemeinsam noch
die lottozahlen angucken wie immer am
mittwoch und hier sind sie 35 11 13 15
40 superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de oder im zdf textseite 557
kaum noch regen und schnee aber die
glätte bleibt ein thema beim wetter und
mehr dazu gleich von ostend elli die
kollegin marietta slomka hat fragen an
sachsens ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer im heute-journal 21 uhr 45
wir sagen danke für heute gerne bis
morgen aber erst machen sie sich alle
einen angenehmen haben
[Musik]
ein schon genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter regen und schnee
lassen in der kommenden nacht nach und
auch in der alpenregion wird es
allmählich ruhiger aber hier im südosten
deutschlands kommt ein wenig schnee auf
morgen im tagesverlauf schauen wir in
die nacht so und da gibt es im südosten
vor allem in der ersten nachthälfte noch
regen und schnee und glatte straßen das
lässt aber bald nach nach osten bildet
sich nebel genauso richtung ems
dazwischen gibt es kompakte wolken mit
regen ganz im westen lockert es auf und
das bei temperaturen von minus fünf grad
an den alpen und zwei bis drei grad hier
unter den kompakten wolken nach norden
hin morgen im tagesverlauf ab neben der
regen im norden hier wird es allmählich
trockener an der ostsee lockt hat es auf
und auch nach westen und im südwesten
da gibt es sonnenschein aber die
richtung bayerischer wald da kommt etwas
schnee auf und das bei temperaturen
höchste werte mit minus 2 grad am
alpenrand und 5 grad in der mitte die
nächsten tage am freitag kommt
gefährlicher gefrierender regen von
südwesten auf schnees auch dabei bei
minus ein bis plus sechs grad und das
wochenende wird durch wachsen vor allem
im westen deutschlands ein schöner abend